Consider that we are viewing this object.
It is being illuminated by a white light source
and the camera is returning these RGB values
or tristimulus values. Imagine now that the
intensity of the white light source is being
reduced. What we observe is that the appearance
of the object changes but clearly the color
of the object itself cannot change because
the color is a material property of the object—an
apple is still red, even if it is in a dark
room—and what we observe is that as the
lighting level has been reduced the tristimulus
values have changed; they have all become
smaller, but the ratio between the tristimulus
values remains the same and what we would
like to do is to find some way to transform
the three tristimulus values to one brightness
value and perhaps two color values.
One way to do this is to transform the RGB
values into chromaticity coordinates and we
divide the RGB values by the sum, by the total
tristimulus, we end up with these variables,
little R, little G and little B. And it is
easy to show that these vary between zero
and one. It is also easy to show that they
sum to one. Therefore, one of the coordinates
is redundant and typically we consider just
the little R and little G values.
Consider this worked example, similar to things
we have looked at before: white light falling
on to a red apple and producing this tristimulus
value. Now consider that there is a cloud
in front of the light source, the overall
illumination level has been reduced and the
tristimulus value now has a different value,
smaller tristimulus value then we had before.
Let’s consider a worked example: in the
first case we can compute the chromaticity
coordinates of little R and little G. For
the second case where there was a cloud in
front of the light source, lower overall illumination,
we can compute the chromaticity coordinates
and we can see that they are the same and
what we have been able to do then is to factor
out the effect of intensity and retain just
two numbers which provide some representation
of color.
Let’s consider a two dimensional coordinate
system with the axis little R and little G.
This point where R equals one and G equals
nought corresponds to pure red. Where R equals
nought and G equals one corresponds to pure
green and this point at the origin where R
and G are both equal to zero corresponds to
pure blue.
It is not possible for a chromaticity coordinate
to exist in the space above the blue line
and this comes from the constraint that little
R, plus little G, plus little B has to equal
one.
In an earlier lecture we discussed the concept
of gamma encoding this is where there is a
non-linear transformation between the brightness
of the light entering the camera and the magnitude
of the signal leaving the camera. Almost all
cameras today have gamma encoding in them
and the gamma value is typically around 2.2.
What effect does gamma encoding have on chromaticity
coordinates? We will illustrate this with
another worked example.
We will use the tristimulus or RGB values
from the earlier example with the full sun
and the clouded sun illumination and the first
step is to compute the gamma encoded RGB values,
and they are shown here, and we can do this
very easily and conveniently using MATLAB.
Now let’s compute the chromaticity coordinates
and in the first case it is for the full illumination
condition and here are the R and G values.
For the second case with lower illumination,
we compute the chromaticity coordinates and
we see they are the same as for the first
case. So once again we have factored out the
effect of illumination and we are left with
two numbers which represent the color. For
this case with gamma encoding, we have factored
out the effect illumination and that is a
good thing. But the actual chromaticity coordinates
have a different value to the case we computed
earlier without gamma encoding.